I'm Linda from Yale School of Nursing
and I'm here to teach you a little bit
about the human body and right now we're
gonna focus on the skeletal system that
is your bones every bone I show you is
real so these are real human bones and
I'm going to show them to you and then
describe why they're important in hopes
that you'll learn a little bit about you
and how you work what do you think bones
do
anybody okay they hold they give you
structure there's no question about that
because you're mostly made up of water
or structure what else do they do they
protect right so I described some bones
that protect really important organs and
what do you think these bones are ribs
so these ribs protect what do they
protect this is where I have a little
plastic model to show you ribs are over
this entire area so ribs protect lungs
of which you have to and if you didn't
watch the long section please watch it
because you'll see real lungs whoops
sorry they protect your lungs what is
this a working on bum bum bum right so
your ribs also protect your heart
now largest organ inside the body look
at the size of it goes from one side
almost all the way over to the other
side this is your liver and your liver
is protected by your ribs the liver 500
different jobs the liver does so the
liver is a really important organ
breakfast lunch and dinner go here
stomach and that is protected by the
ribs and then way in the back and you
see these things that are kind of maroon
colored way in the back
those are your kidneys so your kidneys
are way in the back near your waist way
back here in fact if you watch boxing
matches they put belts on boxers and
guess what they call all the belts
kidney belts because that's where the
kidneys are so when you naturally put
your hand on your waist where your
fingers are or where your kidneys are
and your kidneys are protected by the
ribs in the back so we know that bones
are really important to protect name
another protection of a bone that's
really important that we didn't talk
about
another bone that would be really
important and it protects a really
important organs skull right so this is
a plastic model of a brain and so the
brain is bumpy if you feel a brain it's
very very bumpy if you were to take the
bumps away and open the brain up this is
the size of a normal human brain
standard pillowcase is about the size of
a brain how could that fit inside this
skull the only way it can fit in is if
it's rolled up and it's rolled up and
it's put inside the skull it fits
perfectly
so the skull is actually really really
bumpy anything that's really important
we put in a plastic bag your brain is so
important that it's actually in three
plastic bags so they're not really
plastic bags they're called something
but I want you to think of them right
now as plastic bags they have names the
dura mater for example it means tough
mother it is a really hard piece of
plastic that's covering up the brain
then there's a part called the arachnoid
that looks really spider II and then
there's a part that attaches almost
directly to the brain itself and that's
called the Pia mater I don't care about
the names what I want you to know is
anything that's really important is
housed and protected your brain is
protected with three plastic bags all
over the brain what do you see what do
you think these things are blood vessels
you have 60,000 miles of blood vessels
inside you
60,000 months that's enough to pull them
out and go around the globe twice why do
you need 60,000 miles of blood vessels
in you because you need oxygen to get to
every part of your body so this is the
blood stream the oxygen supply to the
brain so this is who you are who you are
really doesn't have to
to do with how pretty your eyes are how
great your smile is how good-looking you
are how talented you are in basketball
or baseball or art or music that's all
here this is who you are it's all your
hopes all your dreams right now it's
keeping your temperature about 98
degrees right now this part's telling
you to breathe 12 breaths a minute this
is keeping you alive and this is you
this is your balance center if you write
really pretty if you can rollerblade if
you can ice skate if you're good at
balance that's what's keeping your
balance so this is all your hopes and
all your dreams and this believe it or
not is only protected by this so I
usually take out a ruler and when I take
out a ruler I make the students measure
it because I think you make the mistake
of thinking this skull is really really
thick it's not really thick it's
actually less than one inch from here
one inch in is brain that's all it is so
think of it this fits perfectly in here
Nagas could be and you only have one
inch from here to bring that's it and
this is not as thick as you think it's
going to be this is very thin here it's
less than a quarter of an inch it's
thick in the back a little thicker in
the front you see those holes that's not
that I dropped it those are your sinuses
you have sinuses up here and it's sinus
is an open space and you have sinuses
here right here do you ever have a sinus
infection you have a sinus infection you
feel like oh my head is so stuffy my
nose is so stuffy I can't breathe that's
because those sinuses are normally can
you see that hole they're completely
empty but if you get an infection that's
where it fills up with pus and if you
look at where that sinus is can you see
what's close to it your teeth so
sometimes your teeth hurt it's not
because there's a problem with your
teeth
but because there's a problem with the
sinus being filled with pus which is
causing pressure on your teeth so that's
why we call Anatomy learn what lies
beneath you have to know what lies
underneath in order to be able to figure
out what's happening to your person so
this is your Sinus which is right here
so we press right there to see is there
any pain when we think about a sinus
infection is there any pain knowing
where that is is there any pain here for
your frontal sinus so this is again a
real human skull if you look closely at
it and I don't know if the camera will
catch it you can actually see the bumps
of the human brain that is the brain was
in there so long you can actually see
the wrinkles of where his brain was it's
similar to at nighttime when you go to
bed your pillow looks nice and fluffy
doesn't it but when you wake up in the
morning how's the pillow look not so
fluffy anymore you can see the mark of
your head on that pillow
well this bone the brain was in there so
long you can actually see the wrinkles
versus this person the brain that was in
there a much shorter time so instead of
seeing the bumps of the brain you
actually can just see the markings of
where blood vessels cut through the bone
so that this is again a much younger
person but the skull is justice then so
why I bring this had these skulls cut is
I want to really make sure that you
understand this is who you are this is
all your hopes and your dreams lies
inside this organ and this organ is only
protected by this bone so now I'm just
going to describe the bones for you so
how we were made is one big bone two
bones one big bone two bones so the
first big bone is your arm
and this is your shoulder where it goes
in so this is the top part of your arm
it's called the humerus and then it
comes down to this what almost looks
like a hinge of a door and in fact it's
called the hinge joint when you have to
memorize it because the elbow goes in so
we have one arm bone the humerus and
then connect it to that two other bones
so these two bones twist
they twist back and forth that's why you
can do this I can do this because the
arm bones are able to twist around each
other so you can see your humerus fits
inside your ulna and this is how you
move your arm up and down now have you
heard of a funny bone no such thing the
next time you hit your funny bone think
about what's happening you hit your
elbow on a hard surface and all of a
sudden you feel a numbness and tingling
numbness and tingling means a nerve and
that nerve is really just affecting
these fingers so the next time you hit
your funny bone notice nothing happened
to your thumb
nothing happened to your index finger it
is a nerve that lies right in here this
is called the ulna calling me surprised
they call it the ulnar nerve so when you
smashed it
you felt a sharp pain tingling that
tells you that it was a nerve so one big
bone and then two small bones underneath
it this one is your radius so this is
your inner wrist bone this guy is your
outer wrist bone and remember these
bones are kind to twist it and that's
why you can turn your hand back and
forth make sense and then connect it to
these two are about 27 bones in your
hand so these are all your fingers okay
so that's your upper arm now we'll go to
the lower part of your body the lower
part of your body the
is the biggest bone in the human body
and this is the femur it's large and
this is your hip bone so your hip bone
fits inside this bone which is your
pelvis and this is how you walk so you
walk you walk your walk you walk your
walk and if you can look closely at this
bone you're gonna see that it's smooth
but in this area right there it's really
really rough I don't know if you can see
it well enough but it's worn away and
that's what we call arthritis the
wearing away of the bone so now when
this person walks there's actually pain
so because there's pain and sometimes if
you ever have a chicken bone next time
you eat a chicken leg look at the bone
when you get down to the bone there's a
white capsule that covers that bone well
that white capsule that covers this bone
wears away and when bone is on bone the
person has pain and that's when they
need to go get a hip replacement so now
they would go to an orthopedic surgeon
and they would actually measure exactly
the size of your ball that fits inside a
socket that's what they'll call that
joint ball and socket joint makes sense
you know it fits right in there deeply
they'll measure this exact size and come
up with a piece that looks just like
this so this is actually a real piece
that's used for a total hip and the
orthopedic surgeon would take this which
is measured perfectly he would cut this
bone put this bone in and now when the
person goes to walk no problem no pain
because now we took away bone on bone
and now we're on this what I always have
to do is feel the weight of this because
the bone is really solid but this is
much heavier than this is okay so this
is the largest bone in the human body
again one large bone going down to
two smaller bones so we have two choices
these are your lower bones okay this
one's called the tibia I love this one
because this reminds me of an elephant's
trunk can you see how there's a finger
protection coming down okay so that
finger projection coming down is your
inner ankle that's your inner ankle
coming down and this bone is your outer
ankle coming down and can you see how
those two come together to then hold
your foot in place and this again is
your foot so these are again the fingers
look with our toes look very much like
your fingers but this is your heel so
this is how you walk so your foot is on
the ground and you have this bone with
the elephant's nose holding the ankle in
place and then you have the other bone
coming around keeping the other ankle in
place so this is your inner ankle and
your outer ankle make sense so now if
you think about it if you look at them
even which one do you think you break
easier right this guy breaks all the
time this is called the fibula so this
is a much lighter bone compared to this
bone so we start it with big bone here
called the femur two little bones
underneath it the little bones we have
the one with the elephant's nose that's
going to be your inner ankle and we have
your outer ankle and then we have your
foot what am I missing what bone am I
missing here
the kneecap right and this let me find
it is a real kneecap and a real kneecap
is much tinier than you think so that's
your real kneecap and this shows it put
together again inner ankle remember the
one like the elephant's nose outer ankle
your foot and your knee cap on top so
those are the bones of the lower part of
your body
okay then the bones were missing are
these bones and this is called your
pelvis so now you put the pelvis
together and sometimes books lie so when
you look at a book this bone is always
together but in actuality if you found
them they would be broken apart why
would they be broken apart because
they're held together with cartilage so
when you looked at the skull you didn't
see any nose right did you see any ears
no because they're made of cartilage so
again cartilage holds these bones
together so when you put your hand on
your thigh and you bring it up you're
gonna feel a bump right there that bump
is this bump right here so most people
think the pelvis looks like this it
doesn't it's twisted like this and that
makes sense when you feel that bone
right here okay so when you look at
bones I don't know if you can come in
close enough I want you to notice that
there's holes all over that bone and if
you see the holes all over that bone it
isn't because these were found in 1923
and kept in a closet there's holes
inside the bone because bones are alive
most people think when they look at bone
that they're just dead hard tissue
they're not they're very much alive so
inside you you have blood and blood is
mostly made up of saltwater but it's got
things in it it's got red blood cells
it's got white blood cells and then it's
something we call platelets and
platelets are what stop you from
bleeding every second you are alive you
must produce 3 million new red blood
cells white blood cells and platelets 3
million so if I count down by seconds 3
million 6 million 9 million
12 million 15 million 18 million that's
how many cells you have produced in the
last 5 seconds where are those happening
where are you producing them you're
producing them in bone
so when you look at bone you will see
holes all over the bone and those holes
are where the blood vessels are coming
out feeding the new supply of red blood
cells to the rest of the body makes
sense so 206 bones in the body this is a
bone I didn't show you these are your
wings out the back we call them your
scapula and this is where your arm clips
on now this is the most frequently
dislocated bone in the body
no doesn't that make sense look at
what's to stop it from coming out the
back so I know some of you will babysat
and in your lifetime you've done one two
three we with little kids don't do one
two three week this is not this is not a
really really good joint versus look at
this joint look how that bone really
fits inside that hole so so this is in
there much deeper so you can see
actually switch you can see this fits in
really really deeply and what we have is
ligaments that hold that bone in place
but sometimes people dislocate their hip
now how could that happen you'll see it
in football injuries where somebody
sweeps the knee you see what happened
you'd sweep the leg up and all of a
sudden it would pop up so it's really
important that you think about what
bones need extra protection the bones
that need extra protection are the bones
in your skull because what did I say
this is who you are these are all your
hopes there are all your dreams and this
is only housed inside this and remember
a quarter of an inch here a quarter of
an inch here okay so we want to protect
our head as much as we can how are we
going to do that by wearing a helmet
what other bones protect us the ribs so
what are we going to do every time we
get in the car put on a seat belt
because your lungs are protected your
heart your liver your stomach your
kidneys by your ribs but real human ribs
are not as strong as you think they are
okay so I think I've now showed you most
of the bones in the human body the last
few bones I wanted to tell you about
we're right here and this is where you
hear from so if you were to put this
skull near my eyes you could see that
we're pretty much aligned and you can
see where my ear is you can see that's
where my ear is but that hole down lower
can you see that hole that's actually
where you hear from so this is
essentially like a microphone that's
grabbing sound in and bringing it down
lower to where the three tiniest phones
in the human body are and these bones
are so tiny you could see in my box of
bones I would lose these these are your
ear bones so these three tiny bones that
sit inside the human body or what allow
you to hear